letzte woche habe ich in diesem video
erklärt warum wir noch in diesem
jahrhundert nicht an einer über- sondern
vielleicht sogar an einer unter
bevölkerung leiden könnten aber bis es
soweit ist wird es erstmal natürlich
immer mehr menschen auf diesem planeten
geben mehr menschen die wohnraum wasser
und natürlich auch essen brauchen bis
2050 müssen wir unsere weltweite
nahrungsmittelproduktion laut experten
um 60 prozent steigern damit wir den
bedarf gerecht werden
dabei bringt diese
nahrungsmittelproduktion unseren
planeten heute schon an seine grenzen
über ein drittel der weltweiten
landflächen werden für die
landwirtschaft genutzt
dort werden dann über zwei drittel des
wassers eingesetzt und 14 5 prozent
aller durch den menschen verursachten
treibhausgase sind nur auf die
herstellung von fleisch zurückzuführen
hinzu kommt der verheerende einfluss von
monokulturen müll und pestiziden und man
kann sich schnell vorstellen warum wir
dringend nach lösungen suchen sollten
eine dieser lösungen könnten in senken
seien
das essen der zukunft werden sie auch
von experten genannt ob das wirklich
schmeckt das werden jacob vom kanal
breaking up und ich testen denn wir
werden einen burger aus echten würmern
essen
der jurist
michael lehner ins ex-iwf-chef
weinbergen keyboard ja den sekten kann
man tatsächlich essen es gibt über 1900
uns bekannte insektenarten die für
menschen nicht nur s bahn sondern auch
ziemlich gesund sind proteine mineralien
gesunde fettsäuren ballaststoffe und
sogar vitamine kann man alle in grillen
fliegen lassen oder würmern finden
tatsächlich essen wir menschen schon
insekten seit es uns gibt und wir tun es
heute noch für ein bis zwei milliarden
menschen gehören insekten zum ganz
normalen speiseplan nicht aus not
sondern weil es schmeckt und viele
nährstoffe hat nur in der westlichen
welt ist die ente mofa g etwas aus der
mode gekommen für viele ist die
vorstellung sogar ziemlich eklig für
mich übrigens auch ich freue mich
tatsächlich überhaupt nicht darauf
diesen burger zu essen da ganz schnell
so bilder von ganzen gewusel im kopf hat
wie sieht es bei euch würdet ihr gerne
würmer essen ich hab mir mal so eine
umfrage erstellt
es gibt vier antwortmöglichkeiten ja hab
ich schon mal ausprobiert ja würde ich
gerne noch mal ausprobieren
ja aber nur wenn die insekten
verarbeitet sind also man nicht erkennen
kann dass es insekten sind oder nein
sowas kommt nicht auf den tisch gerne
beantworten würde mich mal interessieren
wie ihr zu dem thema steht insekten sind
aber nicht nur für uns sondern auch für
den planeten toll sie benötigen viel
weniger wasser verbrauchen nur einen
bruchteil des co2 der fleischproduktion
und benötigen gleichzeitig auch viel
weniger platz
aber das beste ist eigentlich dass sich
insekten von abfällen ernähren können
erste von supermärkten restaurants und
das was wir in die biotonne packen
verwandeln die kleinen krabbler schnell
und effizient in wertvolle nährstoffe
aus knapp zwei kilogramm essen kann man
ein kilogramm grillen machen für die
gleiche menge rindfleisch benötigt man
acht bis zehn kilo
das liegt vor allem daran dass insekten
kaltblüter sind warmblüter müssen
ständig energie aufwenden um warm zu
bleiben die insekten können diese
energie direkt in ihr wachstum stecken
aber wie funktioniert so eine insekten
produktion überhaupt ein insekt das
gerade von vielen unternehmen überall
auf der welt getestet wird ist die
schwarze soldaten fliege
sie wird zu beginn in flughäfen gehalten
wo sie zwei wochen lang eier legt aus
den eiern schlüpfen dann laufen die im
optimalfall mit nahrungs abfällen
gefüttert werden alternativ kann man sie
aber auch in flüssignahrung tauchen
nach sechs bis sieben tagen sind die
larven dann so groß dass sie verwertbar
sind und getötet werden
manche insekten werden an dieser stelle
getrocknet schockgefroren und später
direkt als snack verkauft doch noch ein
bisschen gewürzt dazu aber eigentlich
kann man sie dann direkt zur tram
schießen
oft werden insekten aber auch gemahlen
dann wird flüssig von fest getrennt öl
läuft ab und es bleibt ein mail übrig in
dem die nährstoffe enthalten sind
das öl ist dann wiederum verwertbar als
biologischer schmierstoff oder sogar als
kraftstoff wer sich jetzt fragt ob
dieser prozess nicht schmerzhaft für die
insekten ist der stellt eine sehr gute
frage eine frage bei der sich auch viele
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
unsicher sind manche sagen dass insekten
ihre umwelt wahrnehmen
sie können sehen hören und riechen und
reagieren über ihr nervensystem auf
diese sinneseindrücke andere sagen dass
insekten die welt anders wahrnehmen als
wir es tun
sie nehmen zwar eindrücke wahr und
reagieren auch darauf spüren aber keinen
schmerz dieser müsse nämlich auch
emotional verarbeitet werden wofür das
nervensystem der meisten insekten nicht
ausreiche auf jeden fall haben sich die
hersteller darauf geeinigt dass die
insekten endlich benutzt ihre möglichst
schnell und human geschlachtet werden
eine alternative für vegetarier sind
insekten auf jeden fall nicht da sollte
man sich vielleicht wie bei algen oder
pilze anschauen die auch schon als essen
der zukunft gehandelt werden wie beim
strom wird es hier wahrscheinlich in der
zukunft auf einen guten mix an kommen es
gibt nicht die eine alternative die alle
unsere probleme auf einmal löst über
algen haben wir übrigens gerade auf
instagram berichtet da posten wir jeden
tag einen beitrag aus dem bereich der
wissenschaft wichtige neuigkeiten
spannende erfindungen oder einfach
schöne bilder mit interessanten fakten
manchmal post auch themen aus denen
leider kein ganzes doktor watson video
werden konnte sich aber trotzdem mit
euch teilen wollte also schaut mal
vorbei um euch über eigen zu informieren
und folgt mir gerne damit ihr immer auf
dem laufenden bleibt es lohnt sich auf
jeden fall
ich finde mich at doktor watson auf
instagram bruder der erste link unten in
der video beschreibung wenn jetzt wie
ich seid dann denkt ihr euch
wahrscheinlich
ist ja schön und gut dass die toll für
die umwelt sind und vielleicht sogar
gesund ich es die trotzdem nicht dann
kann ich euch beruhigen selbst wenn man
die insekten nicht selber ist können sie
immer noch der umwelt helfen zum
beispiel das futtermittel das oft
eingesetzte soja wird zum beispiel meist
in brasilien produziert und dann einmal
quer über den planeten verfrachtet um
hier tiere zu füttern die wir wiederum
essen umweltfreundlicher wäre es hier
vor ort insekten zu produzieren und
diese an die tiere zu verfüttern
allerdings ist das aktuell in der eu
nicht erlaubt nach der bse krise vor 20
jahren wurde das verfüttern von
tierischem protein an nutztiere verboten
das gilt allerdings nicht für menschen
wir dürfen insekten ohne probleme essen
und genau das werden jacob und ich jetzt
auch tun
gemeinsam haben wir hier in köln einen
burger laden besucht der seit kurzem
einen waschechten insekten burger
anbietet grundlage sind hierbei so
genannte buffalo würmer die wie eben
beschrieben zu einem feinen mehl
verarbeitet und mit soja und gewürzen zu
pettys geformt werden statt sie zu
grillen landen diese partie ist
anschließend in der fritteuse und dann
entsteht so einen falafel ähnlicher
bratlinge der dann zusammen mit salat
zwiebeln und soßen auf dem bürgermädchen
und schließlich auf unseren tellern
landen
[Musik]
das sind sie die insekten bürger wenn
ich die bilder mir angucke von diesen
tieren weiß ich nicht wie das essen
möchte krabbelte was man einsparen lässt
sich ziemlich gut aus also das sind
jetzt diese buffalo würmer 27 prozent
von diesen partie sind tatsächlich
bestehen aus diesem wurm mehr hast du
hunger total ja ich hab das ich heute
noch
ja und ich habe mich trotzdem so ein
bisschen davor
ich verstehe nicht wie man dieses geld
mit dem ganzen team will man die sich so
übereinander aber ich meine die
zusammensetzung also in diesem sind
weder keinen unterschied
unappetitlich
das mag im ersten moment erstmal sowieso
nicht so viel ich glaub ich mal nur so
ein stückchen von dem fleisch
es schmeckt gut also ich finde es
schmeckt erstaunlich okay es schmeckt
nicht nach fleisch ist also es wird
jetzt niemanden verraten dass ihr
fleisch isst man sieht dass man schmeckt
ist daran hat auch eine andere
konsistenz
aber ja den bürger wo ja auch ganz viel
salat drin ist und sowieso und tomaten
und gurken und sowas ist jetzt echt
überhaupt kein problem für mich also ja
ich bin die konsistenz gar nicht so
unterschiedlich und bin ja erst recht
knusprig außen dran das ist das was ein
bisschen irritiert umsonst aber jetzt
habe ich die bilder aus dem kopf heraus
also ihr schmeckt einfach gerade weil
sich dann interessant wenn es gibt ja
allen burger und das ist ähnlich wie
finde ich das passt also denke ich noch
viel versprechen hat mich nicht auch
interessant wenn ich sagen dass du was
ist die ernährung der zukunft eigenen
bürger würde ich über insekten bürger
setzen
die sind dann tatsächlich auch noch
aktuell viel viel teurer also insekten
sind jetzt schon wirtschaftlich sehr
sinnvoll eigenen braucht habe ich noch
ein bisschen aber da arbeitet man aber
dankend also die zukunft sich hier ich
war einer vertikal fahren also ist gast
weil die da in großen schritten die
preise reduzieren wird
und in so ländern die über unsere wo
zieht da schon das den staat also wenn
euch das angucken wollte auf breaking up
seinem kanal konnte ich das anschauen
wie diese vertical fahrende nacken
aussieht welche sehr viel spannendes
darüber wie zum beispiel salate tomaten
alles mögliche quasi angebaut werden
kann
mitten in der stadt und vertikal und vor
allen dingen viel viel schlauer weil die
effekte wie die gravitation genutzt
werden die die pflanze beeinflussen und
das wachstum der pflanzen beeinflussen
das perfekte licht wird genutzt und vor
allem sie haben ein system entwickelt
das einfach posten garagen und so rolle
enden gebaut wurde das einfach super
super günstig ist also ich war total
baff und das ist ein super spannende
folge und weil ich eine
geheimhaltungserklärung unterschrieben
ist an sich denken gegangen top secret
video aber mit talk köln information
mein fazit jetzt hierzu das ist
tatsächlich erstaunlich lecker ist es
sehr gut ich kann zu empfehlen wenn euch
überwinden könnte dann guten appetit
also ich kann auch nur sagen es schmeckt
wie normaler bürger wird
also wirklich minimal unterschiedlicher
würmer ok klickt jetzt hier damit ihr zu
jacobs video kommt und seht wie die
vertical farm in aachen aussieht
ansonsten mich vergessen folgt uns gerne
auf instagram doktor watson oder auch
der erste link unten in der video
beschreiben wir posten jeden tag eine
spannende news aus dem bereich der
wissenschaft wie immer fiel lag fürs
zuschauen und bleibt neugierig war
cedric